foreign
in 1972
the U.S passed a landmark piece of
legislation
the new law was called Title IX
and it expanded economic and educational
opportunities for women especially in
higher education
back then
there was a 16 percentage point gap in
the awarding of college degrees in favor
of men within a decade women had caught
up
and then just blew right past the men
today there's an 18 percentage point gap
in the awarding of college degrees
so there's a bigger gender gap today
in U.S higher education than there was
50 years ago when Title IX was passed
it's just the other way around
I study inequality for a living and for
most of my career I focused on the
divides of class and race
but in recent years I've just been
noticing more and more gender gaps and
not in the direction that I was
expecting
probably like most of you I'm used to
thinking about gender equality and the
goal of gender equality is synonymous
with the advancement of women and girls
but it's now clear that there are many
boys and men
have fallen behind and that we have to
be able to think about gender inequality
in both directions
one thing that makes that hard is that
the changes have been so quick so rapid
that it's hard to update our beliefs to
match the new facts it's a bit like the
needles on a compass swinging around
suddenly North is south and South is
North it's really quite disorienting
but it's clear that on some measures at
least now men are lagging quite a way
behind not least on college campuses
that reflects the fact that boys are
trailing girls throughout the education
system
two-thirds of the top academic
performers in high school measured by
GPA are girls
and two-thirds of those at the bottom
are boys
it's not just in the U.S if we look at
the 20 most economically Advanced
countries in the world there's on
average a 13 percentage point gap in the
share of young men and young women with
a college degree with young women much
more likely to have a college degree and
in some Nations the Gap is much bigger
in Norway for example
there's almost a 20 point yeah
and just like in the US these
differences at the college level reflect
what's happening earlier in the school
system
it used to be that maybe boys were ahead
in math and science girls were ahead in
in reading and language in roughly equal
measure that's not true today
internationally at the age of 15 there's
a five-point Gap in favor of boys in
math there's essentially no Gap in
science slight Gap in favor of girls
actually in science
but boys the 30 points behind
girls
at the age of 15 in reading and language
skills
but not all boys and men are struggling
in the same way the intersection of
gender with class and race really
matters here so boys from poorer
households and middle of class
households much less likely to attend
college than girls from the same
background
but there's a much smaller Gap at the
top of the economic ladder
I think one of the reasons the elites
can sometimes struggle to grasp what's
going on with boys and men is that the
the gender gaps are just much less Stark
in affluent communities
and the gender gaps are even more Stark
for black Americans
for every black man getting a college
degree there are two black women
so anybody who really cares about boys
and men
has to care about racial Injustice and
economic inequality
and anybody who really cares about
racial Injustice and economic inequality
has to care about boys and men
now the fact that the education system
doesn't seem to be working very well for
lots of boys and men is obviously not
intentional
there wasn't there wasn't a feminist
conspiracy
a hundred years ago
to say well it might take a century but
eventually we'll overtake them
especially as it was Men Who mostly
designed the school system
what's happened is that as the
artificial and sexist barriers that were
placed in front of women and girls have
been successively removed so their
natural advantages in the classroom have
been revealed
compared to girls boys face two big
structural disadvantages in Education
First
their brains simply develop later
the skills of planning organization and
impulse control are associated with the
prefrontal cortex which develops in
adolescence especially but about a year
later on average for boys than for girls
so there's a significant difference
there in the timing of brain development
social scientists refer to those skills
planning organization Etc as
non-cognitive skills
I like to think of them as chemistry
homework skills
you know doing your chemistry homework
requires a lot of steps
you have to be paying attention in class
when the assignment is given you have to
make a note of it you have to remember
hours later that you're supposed to do
it
you have to actually sit down and do it
instead of something more enticing
instead and remember it's chemistry
homework so that's everything
sorry I know there are some chemists
here I'm sorry
and then turn it in
that's a lot of steps right that's the
law
getting your homework done requires your
impulse control to match what
psychologists refer to as sensation
seeking basically that urge to go and do
something more fun more exciting
and even in the most difficult years of
adolescence which are also the crucial
years for educational success
girls have a reasonable balance
between impulse control and sensation
seeking
but it's a very different story for
adolescent boys they have higher levels
of sensation seeking and with that less
developed prefrontal cortex
they have significantly lower levels of
impulse control
again on average
now
if you still don't believe me
go into any 9th or 10th grade classroom
and ask all the students to open up
their backpacks
most
many at least other girls will have
pretty carefully organized nicely
labeled binders
and for many if not most of the boys it
will resemble a small controlled
explosion
it's not that girls are smarter than
boys
there's no gender gap in intelligence
levels in either direction
it is just that girls develop more of
these non-cognitive skills these
chemistry homework skills
somewhat earlier than boys do
that's just a fact
but it is a fact that we ignore in
education policy
second big structural problem that boys
face in the classroom is the lack of
male teachers
after falling for decades the share of
K-12 teachers who are male in the US is
now just 23 percent
and falling
and the lack of male teaches matters for
at least three reasons first
for many children can be an important
male role model perhaps if they
especially if they don't have one at
home and second male teachers appear to
be more sensitive
to the specific challenges of boys in
the classroom
I can I can vividly remember my own
experience I can actually still feel
what it was like to sit for what felt
like hours on end
on a incredibly hard plastic chair and
that it was actually a male primary
school teacher Mr Cole who gave us more
opportunities to move around made the
lessons a little bit more Interactive
and the third reason male teachers May
matter is there's some evidence that
especially in subjects like English
which is where the boys have fallen so
far behind having a male teacher seems
to dispel the idea that reading and
writing just aren't for me or for people
like me in a similar way to how having a
female teacher has historically helped
girls in stem subjects
right now in too many of our schools
our boys feel like Square pegs being
forced into round holes
and too often our response is to try and
fix the boys
rather than fix the schools
the problems of boys are turned into
problems with boys
if they struggle to sit still or pay
attention or apply themselves to a task
they may be diagnosed with some kind of
disability their problems are thus
medicalized and often medicated
in the US today 23 percent of school-age
boys have been diagnosed with some form
of Developmental disability
twice the rate for girls
ADHD as you might expect is the most
common
but really
when one in four of our boys
has a developmental disability
it seems clear to me that it is the
system which is disabling
rather than the boys who are disabled
now there's a lot we can do to make the
education system work better for boys
let's start with those two big problems
of later brain development and lack of
male teachers so first we should start
Boys in school a year later
and the idea there is to level the
playing field given those differences in
the timing of brain development
and actually that's already quite common
practice a private schools and then lots
of affluent communities but it's
actually not the boys from Rich families
will benefit the most from that extra
year it's the boys from lower income
poorer neighborhoods and families who
would most benefit from the gift of
extra time for development and that's
why I think this should be a question of
public policy
second we need to recruit hundreds of
thousands more male teachers especially
in subjects like English where the boys
are struggling so much and which is the
subject men are least likely to be
teaching
and here I think we can draw some really
good lessons from the successful
movement to get more women and girls
interested in stem subjects so that
means setting clear targets launching
public campaigns
and offering Financial scholarships to
men who want to enter teaching as a
profession
of course those are changes that will
take time those are long-term changes
and there are there are millions of boys
and men who are struggling right now
and so if you're a parent or a teacher
working with a boy or a young man who's
in difficulty right now my message to
you is first
be careful not to even inadvertently
judge him against a female standard or
blame him if he's struggling in a system
that just might not be working very well
for him recognize and respect the ways
in which he's different
don't say
why can't you be more like your sister
try not to even think that
it's very important that we don't treat
our boys as if they were malfunctioning
girls
and the second message to those people
cousins parents neighbors friends uncles
coaches anybody working with a boy or
young man who is struggling right now is
simply thank you
thank you
they do need you
of course
doing more for boys and men doesn't mean
doing any less for women and girls
right that's like saying to the parent
of a son and daughter you're only
allowed to care about one of them
and it's the kind of Zero Sum thinking
that is doing so much damage to our
politics and to our culture we can think
two thoughts at once we can do two
things at once
two thoughts at once two things at once
that's why Norway
a country that's made huge Investments
quite rightly for women and girls but
where boys and men have now fallen
behind on many measures has launched a
commission for boys and men
I've talked about education today
but there are many other areas where
many boys and men are struggling
including in mental health including
suicide risk
loneliness and belonging Family Life
employment
and I don't think we can afford to get
this wrong
if there are real problems in a society
and responsible people don't acknowledge
and address them
irresponsible people will exploit them
and that is already happening on this
issue both online
and at The Ballot Box
we cannot leave a vacuum
by neglecting this issue
the future cannot be female
nor of course
can the future be male
the future has to be for every single
one of us every boy and girl we have to
rise together
thank you
thank you Richard thank you I've got a
customer okay come this way
um so look you gave great advice there
for the system as a whole for teachers
for parents but suppose you're a 14 year
old boy listening to this talk what
would you say to him
well the first thing I'd say is if you
are struggling at school or in some
aspects of your life that's almost
certainly not just your fault it may be
the system's just not working for you
the second thing I would say is
we see you
we got you we understand we've got your
back and the third thing I would say is
don't follow the people who say that the
reason you're struggling is because
women are flourishing or because of
feminism or because of changes in
society that we somehow have to in order
to lift boys up we have to somehow push
women and girls back down again don't
fall for that understand that we only we
get that you're struggling but don't
turn this into zero-sum don't turn to
some of the darker corners of the
internet where unfortunately that is the
message many of our boys are getting but
the first part that's really important
they that whole conversation that we had
about belonging is wonderful difference
in belonging if if our boys don't feel
like they belong
that we've got them that we see them
they're going to be much more vulnerable
to those voices so don't listen to those
voices but we need them to listen to us
instead thank you so much thanks again
thank you